oh yeah I mean just look at this let's
look at this size comparison guys see if
I can get you a good look here alright
so here's the original and then we have
this little guy
alright let's get to this unboxing guys
so here it is pop this little tab right
here first-ever unboxing just realize
that watch you know hundreds of
unboxings online throughout the years
I've never done one myself this is kind
of feels very awkward you know you guys
watching me open up a box here but yeah
first time have never opened this you
guys
all right here we go I think we need to
take a little bit more detail and time
to appreciate game
instruction booklets which do not exist
anymore I have to say though Nintendo
has a really nice website set up and go
view the instruction booklets it's
really good actually now I may just see
the controllers and how they compare to
the original
alright so here we go it actually comes
with two controllers okay this is a full
sized snads controller I'm pretty sure
that's full sized we'll find out in a
moment
tease tease tease we've got the second
snez controller pretty nice that it
comes with two so you can get that co-op
gaming going alright so here we have the
I mean do this tiny arty I have the NES
classic over there I didn't know if it
would be any bigger about the same it is
maybe smaller honestly here we go here's
the moment chat boom there it is so the
weird part like seeing it open for the
first time
kind of weird part is obviously the
controller ports aren't actually for
controller ports
they're just uh yeah just kind of runs
across there but dude I mean it is super
tiny means probably just like a hard
drive in here right hard drive running a
Super Nintendo emulator on the back
you've got your HDMI out please saying
so where so where do we plug the
controllers in
oh dude now this I did not know about
yeah so it's like they've got that there
to conceal and then it pops down like
this
[Music]
dude why is it we can never figure out
which way to point things for cameras
all right so that's where the
controllers ago now surprise part of
this unboxing surprise part get ready
for it
drumroll we have oh my gosh do this is
huge we have an original SNES right here
so on the bottom it actually does say
Super NES control deck just like this
one does the model is obviously
different yeah I mean just look at this
let's look this size comparison guys see
if I can get you a good look here all
right so here's the original this
monstrosity which really isn't that big
and then we have this little guy
I think controllers are the exact same
so here's the original controller
[Music]
compare that to this one right here
oh man that one looks so much more fresh
and new
Steve you guys can see the difference oh
yeah you actually can so the bottom one
is obviously the new one see if the
buttons feel better to actually hold on
man these these all controllers this
thing still feels good right now this is
the old one they don't make them like
they used to ball this they don't make
them like they used to
I do not see like the wall port to it
let's see AC adapter sold separately
Nintendo come on come on into them smell
it oh how could I forget just go down
the side here just put on the side with
free nationwide talking five dollars not
not uh not all the smell to it to be
honest it could be because I have dark
chocolate chips in my mouth right now so
that's all I can smell alright let's try
the ports here nope nope no smell there
all right controller come on the
controller's got to have a little
plastic smell to it
nope do nothing nothing man it's like
Nintendo just like sucked all of the air
out of this thing before they where they
sent these out